[Music]
what's up guys dimitri pascal oda here
for the score eSports now rocket league
is a game with an incredibly high skill
ceiling and nothing is a better
indication of that than the shots that
make use of that ceiling literally
squishy is there because of course he is
and this is his shot now for those who
don't know a ceiling shot in rocket
League is when a player uses the ceiling
to propel themselves into the ball it's
extremely tricky to land but the results
can be incredible so without further ado
here are the top 10 ceiling shots in
rocket League pro quest kicking off our
list at number 10 is triple trouble and
this incredible ceiling shot set up
during the our LCS season seven the
latest additions to the our LCS found
themselves down three goals to
mousesports but that didn't stop these
rookies from nailing this beautiful
triple touch off the ceiling yeah I mean
tigre was far post in a spot where a lot
could just get to it and squeeze it in
and that a fancy way to end it but that
looked good a little bit of a free sub
II stayed in the air kid boosting are
you kidding me taking the number 9 spot
on our list is flipside tactics as
mystic from the ballistics rocket League
brawl already ahead 3 nothing in the
first game of the set the European squad
goes absolutely ham on parallax
seriously at this point they're just
styling on Lancer in game number 1 is a
firm no they come on
looks like tactics playing with power
locks the same way they played against
trouble juggle
I thought is incredible mystic coming
off the ceiling the free pass from Yukio
mystic was already on his way that is
just how do you play against that coming
in at number 8 is the Chiefs torsos who
shows us that there's no such thing as
an impossible angle playing against icon
at the rocket League gauntlet number 5
the Chiefs needed to break the tie and
this beauty from the Outback did just
that
that is pot from CJ CJ to get some time
for his teammates to pick up some boost
careful of that touches maybe a bit too
far behind his teammates and there is a
direct touch from torsos he not just
Chiefs ahead what a beauty from the
Outback to the top and back down in nice
and fast doesn't take his time just
finds the angle it's clean it's simple
but that's all you need to win a rocket
League game at the number 7 spot we have
an oldie but goodie
courtesy of cloud 9 squishy muffins one
of the only players who managed to fit
the ceiling shot in the competitive meta
squishy puts on an absolute show against
Brotherhood during the universal open
rocket League with this unbelievable
ceiling shot someone oh here three
minutes and 15 seconds up more than
enough time he's going to make a
comeback as we saw in the last game they
only even about 15 there comes the
pressure from then
[Applause]
incredible look he brings more up off
the sidewalk and even lands on purpose
the reason he lands on that ceiling I've
raised it before in the last qualifier
the ceilings lets you maintain your foot
for as long as you have one in a half
seconds you might landing on the ceiling
and falling instead of jumping he can
keep that lip the defender has no idea
whence which is gonna be shooting on the
net what an incredible display of the
canvas coping sweet home
coming in at number six is n RGS Garrett
G who hits this godly ceiling shot
against Dignitas at the RLC s grand
final now this will be the first time
you'll see the series on this list and
carat G hints as to why locked in to a
scoreless game against Dignitas Garrett
she capitalized off of turbo pulses bump
and delivered a beautiful shot from the
heavens boost though try still do
something he's much too gather up a
little loose pass steals the mid pieces
well that's gonna slow down some dick
testing we're now on the defensive
[Applause]
they don't
that's
getting bumped into the ceiling landing
and using the flip preset decide that
play with no boosts talk about a
statement showing us no fear at the
number five spot is Evil Geniuses
Chicago being a rookie at the biggest
land of your career can definitely put a
lot of pressure on you but Chicago takes
this pressure in stride as he lands this
shot out of nowhere at the our LCS
season six world championship and he's
flicked it high challenge setting
another one on net but Express will have
that away this Chicago again to the
ceiling no replay worthy goal of the
world championships Chicago goes up off
the crossbar puts that one in the back
of the net and Evil Geniuses with the
one goal lead right at halftime ice in
his veins with his team facing
relegation to the lower bracket Chicago
comes through as he has all season for
Evil Geniuses taking the number four
spot on our list is a lot who shows us
the angle of the century kicking off the
series against maakad east boards during
the are LCS season for league a lot
blows the door wide open with simple but
effective positioning as he nails this
near-perfect ceiling shot creating the
angle of the century impossible taking
that shelf but levering it towards the
middle off the pitch
now players all over this we caught it
yesterday the B seemingly easier demos
are gonna sue this mucket squad down to
the ground or they unlock puts that one
century I'm going to drop it down for a
teammate but a steady goes for the angle
internet a lot out of his mind one way
to open up the series unbelievable oh
pretty Gulf estas on fair with my peak
to open up with that man you overtime
goal with that coming in at the number
three spot is yet another highlight from
the are LCS season five world
championship grand final series between
NRG and Dignitas in the grand final
there's no greater pressure but
nonetheless being down three games to
one
Guerra G stepped up once again and
showed the opposing Dignitas that they
weren't going to go down without a fight
just in a pie energy trying to
reciprocate - what team Team Dignitas
did to them earlier on keep the ball up
high do not allow any time to remain on
the clock as Guerra looked for their
ceiling shot
ferrets
you give him the space and he'll make
you fade but the carpet we've had to
ceiling shots in our Grand Finals what
else is there that these teams can do
this play from Dignitas is violent panda
maybe from that exact same series as our
last entry but there's just no way we
could leave it off our list let alone
the runner-up spot there's a reason this
grand final is considered one of the
best in the game's history tied 2-2 and
on the brink of resetting the bracket
violent panda takes the ball off the
ceiling all the way to a bracket reset
if I'm here to get enough control before
they drop back to defense the delegates
got the
[Applause]
homey homey
I'd say what number like his response to
doing that I looked across he sweats his
hat no big deal
few shots have helped define the endless
skill ceiling of rocket League like
squishies ceiling shot against method at
the our LCS season four World
Championships which is why it takes the
top spot on our list with car control
never quite seen before squishy
maneuvered his way through all three
method defenders clocking in over three
seconds worth of airtime and in the
process solidifying himself as a legend
of the game no shot propelled rocket
League eSports quite like this one
he almost had a touch just fell short
hope the press is not building up too
much on him now the final minute this
was the score line at game 3 cloud 9
unable to take it and he pulls it up
here in the most clutch moments the
player to invent the shot
and just destroy a method on defense
even they have to be impressed
incredible showcasing squishy absolute
obliteration if you look over at squishy
on the stage he's still just stone-cold
killer how do you not smile doesn't even
care well guys that's our list now if
you find yourself craving more car ball
content be sure to check out our story
of rocket League like this video
subscribe to our Channel and be sure to
let us know in the comments what other
rocket League related top 10s you'd be
interested in seeing see you next time
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]